[Applause]
hahahahaha
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
[Music]
call that ambulance son you gone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
fight
[Music]
perfect
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rowdy
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fight
[Music]
want to be featured in ochoto tv send in
your clips by following these steps
before you submit your clips make sure
the quality of the video is clear
put your ign as a file name for your
video
limit submissions to three to five clips
a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your clips on it avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play until the
end of the round
next send your clips via dropbox in the
correct category you can always find it
on the description of every other tv
series
once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name just put
in your ign
[Music]
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
thanks for watching don't forget to hit
like and be sure to subscribe for more
tekken content
[Music]
you